hey youtubers is charlie and back during
my break down of the core of book 3
teaser I asked you guys to submit all of
your questions so I picked 10 of them
with one bonus question to answer in
this video I also wanted to talk a
little bit about the Nickelodeon up
fronts that are coming on March
thirteenth because that might be when we
get our first official look at book
three if you are finding me for the
first time and you're a big anime fan or
just a core fan in general be sure to
subscribe to get all my stuff I try to
do anime stuff at least once a week and
regular core videos especially when it's
in season so first things first let's
talk about the up fronts it's just when
Nickelodeon screen stuff from all of its
upcoming shows for advertisers so that
they buy advertising time during that
it's widely rumored that they're going
to screen new footage from Korra book 3
and reveal the official premiere date if
you've seen any of my other book through
videos you know I'm expecting it to
premiere either late this spring like as
soon as April or at the latest the
beginning of summer like in May they're
almost done animating book 3 and usually
that's the cue that the premiere is
really really close trailers for new
seasons of Korra typically come a month
or two before the season premieres so
you can bet if we do see an official
trailer in the next month then the
official premiere the series is really
really close now let's answer some of
your questions number one KJ bukan a
asks do you think there will be any
major character deaths in the upcoming
season yes sad face I think it's kind of
implied the Katara might die they
brought together the children of egg and
I don't think it's just because they
look cool together they spent all of
book to healing their relationship and
dealing with their issues the next
logical step now that they're so unified
would be to introduce a major tragedy
that they could all deal with together
and what could be more tragic for their
family than their mother dying to be
fair though if she does end up dying she
did live a very fulfilling life with eng
and her family look at all of her
children all grown up now question
number two Soraya mulchen asks since
they'll be in the Fire Nation at one
point I want to know if we'll be seeing
Zuko so the person that was sitting on
top of the dragon that the White Lotus
person was talking to in the teaser
definitely looks like a very you know
face scar Zuko person I think it's safe
to predict that he'll play a role
hopefully he will be helping team Korra
but we really need an official trailer
with Morsi
to be sure but yes I do think we're
gonna see him question number three tomi
Shen asks either the White Lotus are
helping Korra or they're a corrupt
faction yes I think it's safe to say
that the White Lotus is still you know
very good group they're not evil but
whoever the ones Korra was fighting with
in the trailer they're probably just a
faction or people impersonating White
Lotus members someone also made the
suggestion in the comments sorry I can't
remember who that it could be the
villain in the next book just planting
evil agents inside of the White Lotus
question number four holiday flower girl
asks so if the Fire Nation is going to
be in book three is there a possibility
that we might actually see Zuko's
daughter the Fire Lord I will be so
disappointed if we don't see her we
still don't even know her name which is
one of the things I love about authors
like say george RR martin and JRR
tolkien they have massive appendices at
the ends of their books with every
person's name going back several
generations even if they don't appear in
the book considering all that yes I
definitely think we'll finally meet her
I think the real thing to consider is is
does she take after her father her
mother who was probably may or her aunt
azula Zuko probably would not have let
her become the next Fire Lord if she was
crazy like Azula though question number
five is agog and asks is Cora going to
ride dragons this season so if Zuko and
Aang got to ride Roku's dragon Fang then
yes definitely I think Cora's gonna get
to write a dragon fingers crossed
hopefully Zuko's dragon even if that
person in the trailer is not Zuko I
still think she'll get to ride one at
some point there will be several Fantasy
characters writing dragons this season
and it is going to be awesome question
number 6 wind 01 01 asks since they're
including scenes from the Fire Nation
next season do you think that they'll
tease us with the brief appearance from
missoula so Zuko in his daughter are on
high alert watch so that means they'll
probably be there I'd say that Azula who
will always be linked with Zuko like
macho and Bolin will probably also make
a brief appearance it really depends on
what they're doing in the Fire Nation if
they only travel there briefly then the
chances are really slim but if more of
the story revolves around the fire
nation as a geographical location then
there is a much better chance that we'll
see her but because the story is rumored
to revolve mostly around the earth
Kingdom they're going to be spending
most of their time there question number
7 the midge
the cousins asks do you think that there
will be another avatar series after
Korra so Bryan Konietzko and Michael
Dante DiMartino typically take between
you know 18 months in two years to write
and develop and produce a new season of
Korra they said that they really want to
take a break after book for errors
because they've been working so hard so
if they want to do another series and
Nickelodeon wants to pay for it yes to
new avatar but there would be a long
time between Korra book 4 and book one
of whatever the new series was assuming
they don't start writing it immediately
after book for I would plan on the comic
book filling in that time when there's
no new avatar on television it's a lot
easier to produce than a whole season of
television question number 8 durance GLS
what happened to vatu and is he supposed
to return so based on raava and vowed to
cycle of death and rebirth he'll slowly
grow out of raava over the next 10,000
years big asterisk though I don't think
he's supposed to come back before the
end of book for but theoretically
someone could do the same thing Jinora
did during the finale and bring him back
sooner remember she helped Korra extract
raava from vatu before she grew powerful
enough by herself to just escape they
don't really have gender but she's
voiced by a woman so I choose to use
that pronoun we can talk more about the
mechanics of raava and fought to kind of
extracting each other from each other in
the comments though question number 9
will we get more top in book 3 yes but
mostly in flashbacks although it's
widely debated and on the show they
haven't explicitly said top is dead the
other characters exclusively refer to
her in the past tense and Katara has
said that many of my friends are gone
Zuko of course we know is still alive so
generally I think that they're trying to
imply that she is dead but yes whole lot
of bei Fong backstory coming in book 3
which paves the way for Toph with baby
beifong's flashbacks so get excited
about that question number 10 Caitlin
Lee asks is Asami going to be featured
heavily in book 3 yes she and Korra
aren't going to be frenemies anymore
they're actually gonna be super buddies
I'm sure tumblr will create the most
epic of ships based on their scenes like
I've said there will be much less teen
romance love triangle what not meaning
it will be a lot easier for Korra and
Asami to be friends
so they will have a lot of really fun
scenes together and one last bonus
question vantastic asks since the avatar
connection is broken between Korra and
the past avatars will Aang still be able
to make a cameo yes but like Toph
probably only in flashbacks the children
of eng are all there so they'll also
probably invoke a lot of egg moments
themselves in addition to Korra so thank
you so much for submitting your
questions guys just a lot of fun as
always hopefully there'll be some better
corn news in the next couple of weeks
especially with those up fronts coming
be sure to leave suggestions in the
comments for what you want my next core
video to be about Oscars are this
weekend and I was going to do this
fantasy league video series but in real
life work has been way too crazy so I'm
probably just going to do a winners
reaction / breakdown video in addition
to my Walking Dead and Hannibal episode
1 video right now click here for more
Korra book 3 awesomeness and click here
to learn all about grant gustin's new
flash costume spoiler alert it is super
cool thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys tomorrow high fives
uh